♪ Yeah, okay it's Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Sippin' in some tea ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Puttin' out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Good morning, May 6th,
we are in the building,
"Tea With GaryVee", I am GaryVee.
Big day, thank you.
Big day because Twitch has joined us live
and so before we get into the show,
big shout outs to a lot of the Twitch.
Zeus, what's good?
Michelle Meyers on Facebook, what's good?
Johnny5, what's good,
on Twitch, I love that.
So Twitch family's in the building.
OfficialCozy, great to see you.
"Tea With GaryVee" is here.
Thank you so much, Justanotheramy,
really appreciate it,
really, really appreciate it.
And thanks for everybody else who's
on every other platform,
big shout out to everyone on Instagram.
We go a little bootleg, kind of gotta just
film it like this 'cause it doesn't attach
to the incredible platform
we use, StreamYard,
which has been fantastic for us
and has really helped
create this infrastructure.
Dustinonthe1sand2s, good morning
to you brother, how are you?
- Excellent.
- Real well?
- Yeah.
- Good, bro.
- I can't see the Twitch for
some reason, I don't know.
- In the comments?
- I mean, I see it here within StreamYard,
but I'm trying to just
watch it on my phone,
as if I was a guest...
I don't know, maybe I just
don't know what I'm doing.
- That's highly likely.
- Yeah.
- Let's get into it.
Let's get Jason from Twitch.
Hey.
- Hey.
- What's up, comish?
- How are you?
- I'm well, tell everybody who you are.
This is awesome.
- What a way to start.
- Oh, this is awesome.
- It's so awesome to see you.
Hi, everybody, Johanna Faries,
Commissioner of the Call of Duty League
and it's just an honor to be here.
Good mornin'.
- How've you been, everything well?
- Everything's well, you know what,
we're busier now than we might have been
before this whole crisis hit, y'know.
- So for everybody who's
watching, if you're unaware,
I'm the minority owner
of the Minnesota Rocker,
which is a team in the
Call of Duty League,
and it's been a great venture so far.
And obviously with what's
going on with COVID,
the macro esports landscape
is getting more and more attention.
And obviously we have a format
where people do travel and we do have fans
and we had the opening weekend,
so we've been affected in that way.
But the infrastructure of
our game obviously scales
to this new world.
What's been the biggest observations
from your standpoint?
- I would say, I use this word a lot,
but the resiliency of the
business model, right?
We were cranking on live
events, as you know.
We launched in Minnesota,
you were there, it was fire.
Especially for day one,
and unfortunately this
whole world is going
through unprecedented
challenges, we all know that.
But we're still able to operate,
thanks to technology, and
just what esports affords you.
So I think there's just
been a really cool,
new wave of innovation that's
frankly had to come through
because of what we're going through here.
- And before we get into your question,
how has it been to be a
commissioner of a sport?
It's kind of neat, like...
- Oh, it's the best!
I know you--
- Go ahead.
- I know we talk about this a lot,
just being a part of sports
and whether you want to own a team
or be on the league ops side,
but to be able to head
this up is just an honor.
It's incredible.
- What's been the biggest challenge
and what's been kind of
the most pleasant surprise,
just out of my own curiosity?
- I would definitely say
the biggest challenge is,
I think as you know, "Call of
Duty" is a monster franchise.
It's been around for
so long and the esport
has been around for a
really long time, right?
So there was already these
built in expectations,
built in ways of doing things,
rituals, traditions, the whole nine
that you really have to
respect when you come in.
This is not a brand new,
never-been-done-before,
different proposition for the league.
So we were rebooting,
but we also had to marry that
within honoring the legacy
of where we've been,
so I think that's been
an interesting challenge
and one that we've embraced.
Biggest surprises, we've got
everyone around the horn.
Yourself, we've got some of the
biggest name celebrities
coming through the doors,
we've got these incredible
competitors from the scene,
both new names from pros who are gonna
make their mark going forward,
pros who've been, again, in
the scene for many years.
So I would just say
it's the amount of faces
and interest level in what we're doing,
from people who've known
about it for a long time,
people who are just getting involved,
people coming in from traditional sports.
It's really a interesting
convergence, I'd say,
of a lot of different industries.
- I love it.
Well, it's great to see your face.
Any questions before I move on here?
- No, it's just great to
see you, are you well?
- I am well.
You know, just navigating through this...
The first three, four,
five weeks was really about
a) make sure family's okay,
just really quantifying the disease
and then very, very quickly,
within the first couple days of it,
there's seven companies
under my holding company
that I'm a CEO of,
I'm the CEO of the
biggest company within it.
So, just navigating some of
that world while also navigating
through just getting
crushed in public speaking,
like all of that revenue's gone.
You know, wartime general shit.
- Sure.
- You know?
I think a lot of people signed up for
entrepreneurship over the last decade
'cause it was cool and seemed easy and fun
and the thing to do,
and I think a lot of
people are experiencing,
especially if you're under
32 and you have a business,
you're experiencing for the
first time a punch in the gut,
and really navigating it.
And it's been a fun challenge.
- Yeah, well good luck with it.
- Thank you.
- Good luck this weekend to the Rocker,
we're all really excited to see it.
- Thank you, we're excited about it.
- All right.
- All right, Johanna.
Take care.
- Take care, bye.
- That was a fun surprise, Dustin.
I like you guys, you guys are
up to all sorts of tricks.
Big shout out to everybody on Twitch,
which is exploding here
in the comments section.
If you're interested in being a mod,
we gotta hit up Dustin
or somebody on the team.
Dustin, I don't know if you wanna throw
into the Team GaryVee chat
maybe Zayn or Tyler Schmidt
or somebody who wants to jump into the,
a lot of people throwing
their hands up to be mods,
which could be fun.
There's a lot of incredibly,
the ecosystem that is Twitch,
I think, has a lot of fun, so we'll see.
- Okay.
- Let's keep it movin'.
- What's goin' on, how are you doin', man?
- I'm good Chaz, how are you?
Nice hoodie.
- I'm chilling.
Yeah, thank you, TikToker, you know.
Yeah, so good morning.
- Good morning.
- For anybody who doesn't know me,
my name's Chaz Smith.
I'm a content creator formally on Vine,
now on YouTube, Instagram, TikTok.
I never thought I would be
wearing a TikTok hoodie.
But yo, so my question for
you is as a content creator,
it can be a lot of
emotional ups and downs.
Especially for somebody like me,
I create skits and content that's humorous
and supposed to bring people joy.
So my question is,
during times when I'm not
authentically feeling joyful,
it's hard to be motivated
to create something,
create content.
What advice would you
have for people like that?
- Two things.
So that's a great question, two things.
One, go to sleep.
Like, don't.
You know, forcing it is, you know this,
you've probably had to persevere,
I've gone through it on
stage or in a livestream.
Sometimes there's just
something else on your mind,
there's other things going on
and you can't be that 100, you know?
So one, for content creation,
I think it's okay to not post for a day
or a week or even a month, like,
as much I'm ambitious for
my audience to be, like,
hey three, four times a day
across all these platforms,
40 pieces of content a day...
That's when you're in it.
If you're not in it,
then I think it's super
incredible to not to do it
or take a break or have 36
hours pass and then get on it.
Or, which I think would
be really powerful,
post a piece of content about that.
So, if you're the funny
guy making people laugh
and escapism, but then you post like,
"Yo, today's a tough day, like,
"I'm not in character, like,
"Yo, this is where I'm at."
I think that brings a
lot of value to people.
- Yeah.
Vulnerability.
- Yeah, vulnerability is super powerful
and honestly it's
something I struggle with,
and I in general don't like, y'know,
showing vulnerability.
I don't like talking
about when I'm not in it.
I kinda go in a cocoon.
Like, my whole career,
my whole life really,
if I'm not in a good place
and just kinda quote end quote go to sleep
'cause I'm just not interested
in passing on my negativity
or my struggles on others.
However, when you're in a public domain
there is a level of
showing people humanity
and things of that nature
that could be powerful.
That's highly personal,
but I think one or two are
really good options, Chaz,
in that situation, like,
don't beat yourself up if
you don't go at it for a week
just 'cause you're in a slump
or feel the power to
actually just share like,
"Yo, I'm in a slump.
"I'll be back, just a couple
things I'm working through
"in my dome," y'know?
- Yeah, word.
Follow up question to
that if you got time?
- Yeah, go ahead.
- So, one thing I'm working
on now also especially
while we have this time to slow down
while we're staying at home,
is I'm workin' on building
a greater structure
for, I guess, the business and
financial side of my stuff.
But, going back and forth between that
and creating can be
difficult mentally, too.
Like, what do you do to, I guess,
separate the creative
aspects of your work,
or to go back and forth
between the creative
and business aspects of your work?
Like, I'm sure you hire people
and delegate tasks but...
- For me, those two
things come super natural
because I can be creative
and I am, in general, business-oriented.
But yeah, I think that's right.
I think you figure out, y'know,
whether it's a manager or
something of that nature,
y'know, somebody that you
trust that can hold down,
y'know, the creative part's on you
unless you get a creative partner
who, like, writes or helps
or things of that nature.
But yeah, I think the whole world is based
on doubling down on your strengths
and really sourcing out your weaknesses.
I think that 98% of the people
that are watching right now
spend way too much time trying
to fix their shortcomings
when the reality is the upside
there is slightly, y'know,
a slight growth whereas if
they just went ham on the shit
that they loved and they're best at,
they'd get a ton more value
and then that actually
extracts dollars to be able
to subsidize the things that
they are not as good at.
So, yes I do think hiring
and building teams is super powerful.
- Okay, yeah.
Thank you, man.
I appreciate it.
- I gotchu.
I hope you do well.
- All right, take care.
- Buh-bye.
Mornin', mornin', mornin'.
Big shout out to Twitch.
You guys are lighting
up the comments section.
What's up?
What's up Zavi?
Abel Franco,
Edison Jersey, in the building.
Abel, you keep bringing up
a certain DailyVee episode
and a timestamp.
I need you to put that in
the comments of what that is.
We may just need to get
Abel on the fuckin' show.
Dustin, let's work on that.
Let's get Abel on the show.
All right, let's keep this goin'.
- Hey, Gary!
How are you?
- I'm well, James.
- Best day of my life.
(chuckles)
Five minutes with you.
- Thank you, my friend.
Where are you from?
- I'm from China.
I came here 10 years ago
to do my grad school,
and now I've got my PhD,
everything's sad.
I'm a data scientist,
but it feels like I've already
achieved my biggest dream
which is come to the
U.S. and I was wonderin',
"Whoa, what's next?
"How can I become like Gary Vee?
"My version of Gary Vee."
Y'know, that's my question.
- That's a great question, James.
I think the way to be
your version of me is
to just truly be yourself
and really lean into
what you want to be doing.
I think so much of what I look back at
of the last 20 years,
professionally specifically,
is me just being comfortable being me.
When I first wanted to do
speaking everyone told me
that I couldn't curse.
I kept cursing.
When I started my career I
worked for my dad's liquor store
even though I knew there'd be
certain parts of that, like,
people would judge me of
working in my dad's shop.
But, y'know, when I wanted
to bet the farm financially
on investing in Facebook and Twitter,
I didn't listen to my financial advisors
that were advising the wine
store from a finance standpoint.
I just felt very comfortable being me,
and I think that's ultimately, y'know,
the thing I'm best at
is actually being me.
The thing I'm best at is being Gary.
And I think for not
being your full self is
where most people get into unhappiness.
When they're living for
other people's opinions,
and so I think you just,
and that's really tough
in Asian cultures and parents,
PhD, I get it.
I know the kind of symbols
that make it difficult
but the way you can do it is actually
just being your full self.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
And y'know, like, if I don't
ask I'm just gonna regret it.
I don't want to leave any regrets,
so can I come work for
GaryVee, Team GaryVee.
I probably know your answer already so...
- What do you think you can provide?
Y'know it's a very tricky
time more than ever
in the last 10 years.
We have a fiscal
responsibility that, y'know,
in a world where we have
to let some people go
to make our liquidation challenges work.
It's hard to hire when
you're letting people go.
On the flip side, y'know,
the reality is the answer is maybe.
I think if you email
me at gary@vaynermedia
and tell me what you can do.
I'll have Andy from my
team, who runs my team
and hires for my team, interview you.
No regrets, here's your chance.
- Awesome!
Love you, love Dustin, love
Zayn, like, you guys are great.
- Thank you, brother.
Take care.
- Take care.
- All right, let me get in the
comments here for a second.
Man, I'm really loving the
Twitch action is on fire.
Like, I'm loving it.
Facebook, YouTube, Twitter,
you guys have to rev up your comments here
'cause Twitch is outta control right now.
- Yeah, I was gonna say it's
like twice as much as normal.
- Yeah because fuckin'
Twitch knows how to do it.
That's the beauty of Twitch
when you really look at it.
Like, the sheer energy of the
community reminds me so much
of old school chats and,
like, message boards.
It's true internet culture.
It's true community.
Y'know, I think YouTube has
been pretty strong, Dust,
in the comments.
- Yeah.
- I think Facebook should
be up a little bit.
And I think that Twitter
periscope is kinda low
in comparison, but
Twitch is comin' in here.
We might have to get
into, like, a whole battle
between all the streams
and see which community's the most ham.
So, anyway...
I mean, Twitch is exploding.
Do you have any idea how
many people are on Twitch?
- Yeah, it says on my thing...
It's right under 6,000 for Twitch,
- Okay.
- 3,400 for Facebook,
- Yep.
- 1,600 on YouTube,
and about just under 300 on Twitter.
- Makes sense.
Man, Twitch has got the most already?
- Yeah.
- Love.
- It's staying at 5,991,
so I feel like it's more.
- Twitch fam, I haven't
jammed enough on Twitch
to know how to share it out,
but I would love all of you
to share this stream right now
to as many friends as possible
to create as much awareness for it
whether you use it within Twitch
or whether you use it on
Twitter to drive here so.
All right, let's keep it goin'.
- What's up?
- Nino, what's good?
- How're you doing, Gary?
- Very good.
- Yeah, much love from Germany, man.
I appreciate you, all the positivity you
and your team put out.
It's really inspiring, just appreciate it.
- Thank you so much.
- So, my question is,
maybe to give you first a
little bit of background,
over the last three years I did,
basically I learned my skills.
I got some degrees because I
wanted to work for a big brand.
And after that, I got an internship
with one of the biggest
brands in the world,
and I got the opportunity to work for them
which was amazing.
And, I basically said well
I want to break the door in,
right I have the foot into the door now,
so when I go in,
and I worked my ass off to get there.
And there were a lot of
opportunities opening up
to the end of my internship
but right around that
time Corona broke loose.
So, the opportunities vanished,
and now I'm living in my parents'
basement, basically, again
with 24, which is fine.
So, I said let me lean
into my personal brand
because I'm into fitness.
Been training for, like, eight years.
A little bit over that.
And I'm also a coach,
so I said well I'm gonna
develop my brand a little bit
and push that on Instagram and wherever
because I'm just in it.
But, I catch myself looking back
because I don't wanna miss out
on the corporate world as well
because I love that as well.
I met so many amazing people,
so it's, like, how can I combine them?
- Easily!
Like, y'know, as soon as we
get to some sort of normalcy
and corporations are hiring again,
which they will,
you can apply for a job
or another internship
and be right back there.
Like, this is a moment in time
and the beauty for you is you're so young.
You have your entire life in front of you.
And then, if you want
to do the fitness stuff
in your personal brand,
you can do that after
hours and on weekends.
And the other thing is
you may change your mind
in three years or six years.
- Yeah, true.
- The biggest issue
that I see out there is
that we don't put changing
your mind on a pedestal.
I believe that changing my
mind is my greatest strength
as an operator.
The ability to change
your mind is powerful.
Most people fear changing their mind
'cause they're worried about
what people will judge them for
when just a year ago they said,
"I'm gonna be a fitness coach!"
and then nine months later
they're selling pizzas
and everyone's like, "Oh,
you're full of shit."
And, it's not about being full of shit.
It's you fuckin' changed your mind.
- Yeah, true.
- I think laziness and changing
your mind are two things
that are completely misunderstood.
I think most people think
that changing your mind
is a show of weakness
and you don't know what you're doing.
I think it's the reverse.
People obviously very much
look down on laziness.
Believe it or not for somebody who's like,
"Hard work, hard work."
I actually see laziness as an insight to
that you're not passionate
about that thing,
and you just need to do another thing.
- Yeah.
Helped so much.
- What I'm saying is,
I apologize.
What I'm saying there is you
can do the corporate thing
and then four years later be like,
"Wait a minute.
"Actually I loved being
a health professional."
And then, you can do that and
you still fuckin' be under 30.
- Yeah, true.
Yeah, I don't know.
I just feel stuck right now
because it was always going so fast
and I was ready to kill it, y'know,
'cause I was so go, go, go.
- Brother, there were
people that were ready
to have the greatest life of all time
that got hit by a car and died.
There are people who just
built a monster business
in the 1940s in Europe
and then a war broke out.
There are people who are ready to kill it
and actually died from COVID.
- Yeah.
- Like, the fuck are
you complainin' about?
You know what I mean?
- No one gives a shit, I get that.
- Don't be sad, be happy.
Anybody who's watching right now
if you did not have a
loved one die from Corona,
you need to be happy.
I don't give a fuck about your job.
I don't give a fuck about,
y'know, the missed thing.
I don't give a fuck about
that you missed your favorite concert
or your sporting event.
Like, we need to put shit in perspective.
- Yeah, true.
So true.
- You're winning!
The fact that you have a parent's home
to go to is better than a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- You just need to switch it.
It's kinda like an on/off switch.
Instead of spending your
time thinking about, like,
"Oh God, I'm so unlucky just
when I was finally there
"out of a hundred years this pandemic..."
My friend, do you understand that
if this pandemic started
three months earlier
Kobe Bryant would be alive?
- It's a shame.
- Y'know what I mean?
If this pandemic happened a year ago
at the same time my great friend
and the great unbelievable
young artist, Nipsey Hussle,
would be alive?
Like, bro, don't be sad.
Like, honestly I'm kinda happy.
I'm glad that you got
punched in the stomach
because it's gonna make you
more resilient in the future.
It's gonna make you more thoughtful
when you make decisions in the future
because you've now lived
through shit can happen.
- Yeah, so true.
- Just change your mind.
- Keep it up.
- Yeah, not only keep it up,
realize that this is an opportunity.
- Yeah.
Yeah, man, I'm trying
to learn everyday, bro.
I'm trying to make it work
and just trying to be
the best self everyday
and just, I get what you mean.
Maybe--
- And don't,
Go ahead.
- Maybe one more thing that
relates to that a little.
When I was working there, like,
there were a lot of positive people
and I drew energy from that
because I love to work
surrounded by positive people
because I'm positive as well.
It's just an uncertain time,
but now that I'm back here,
I'm missing, like, the
influence of positive people.
- So, put positivity in your ear.
- I do, man.
That's why I'm talking to you!
- Appreciate it, bro.
So, more!
Why don't you contact
everybody in your phone
and send them a Google Hangout link
and get on everyday at
six o'clock for two hours
and just shoot positivity.
Take the initiative.
Fuck dwelling!
Fucking go all in!
You take control!
You create positivity.
Why don't you text all the fuckin' people
that you found positive and say,
"Hey, man, hey, gal, do you
wanna go on Zoom tonight?
"Let's get 20 of our friends together."
Literally go through your phone
from A to fuckin' Z and find
every positive person you know
and send them a link and say
I'll see you at 8 p.m. tonight.
- Yeah, man, that's a great idea.
- Well, good.
That's what I'm here for.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care, stay well.
- You too.
- Listen, just like I told Nino,
you're in control!
Like, you want positive people?
Go gather them!
You throw the party!
You liked some party that
doesn't exist anymore?
Great!
Go and fuckin' throw your own party!
We're in fuckin' control out here!
You're in fuckin' control out here!
Let's go!
Fuckin' 7,000 people on Twitch.
Let's get this to 10k.
Twitch fam, hit up everybody that you know
that fucks with Twitch.
I'll get my shit together
and really understand
how the platform works.
So, I don't know how you can
message this or share this
or co-screen it or whatever
the fuck you guys do
'cause you're the fuckin' best.
Go do it.
- Hey, Gary!
How are you?
- How are you, my friend?
What's your name?
- I'm good.
I'm Saharan and I'm from
Asia, from Sri Lanka.
- Sri Lanka, very nice.
- Can you hear me?
- I can, yes.
- Okay, so I'll just get right into it.
So, I started like creating
content in 2013, so...
And, like, since then I've
been making content, like...
I'm all good with that.
Like, I've been following my passion.
And I've been making videos
and I've been like...
I'm all good in that side.
You understand what I mean?
- Yes, I do.
You feel good about that.
- So, the thing is...
Yeah.
So, the thing is I'm
struggling to post it, like,
I don't know.
- Oh wait a minute.
So, you can make the content,
but you don't put it out?
- Yeah, I don't.
I don't, like, I make content for others.
It's always been like this...
Telling someone else's
story is easy for me,
but telling my own story
to the world is hard.
- Do you want to tell your story?
Or do you enjoy telling
other people's stories?
Because there's an incredible
amount of storytellers
who are far better about
telling their story
than are people that are
good at telling their story.
- Yeah, but I just want to try,
but I'm, like--
- Are you scared?
Are you scared of what your
parents or relative will think?
Are you scared of what
strangers will think?
Y'know 'cause what you're
worried about is judgment.
- Yeah, I think so I just
wanted to hear that from you.
- I'm here to do it.
- "Stop giving a fuck about it."
(laughs)
- Listen, buddy, I know
that you know the answer
which is why I wanna
go a little bit deeper
which is are you,
do you think you're more worried
about your parents' or relatives' opinion?
Or do you think that you're more worried
about anonymous people's opinions?
What would you say when I ask you that?
- Anonymous people.
Like, my family supports me, like,
to everything that I do.
- That's awesome.
Do you know how to ride a bike?
- Yeah.
- Do you know how to swim?
- No.
- Okay, are you scared of swimming?
- Yes.
- Yeah, I was too as a kid.
Were you scared to ride a bike at first?
- Yeah, of course.
- You putting out content is similar
to swimming and riding a bike.
With swimming, you still haven't done it.
With riding a bike, you were
scared to get hurt and fall off
but eventually you figured it out.
You've had two experiences that are cliche
to almost every child of, like, two things
that one could fear
and you figured one out
and you haven't figured out another one.
That's who you are with content.
You need to become the Saharan
that learned how to ride the bike,
not the one that has
stayed away from swimming.
You understand?
- Yeah, like, I have a superpower,
I call it my superpower,
because, like, if I put
some content out, like,
it blows up!
Like, my first TikTok video
got, like, 400,000 views.
And same on YouTube, it blows up.
- So, you're a great content creator.
- Yeah, I know it, like,
I'm scared of posting.
So, thanks for that advice
and one last thing before I go.
- Please.
- Can you please follow
me on Instagram, like,
it would really boost my confidence
to, like, post some real shit.
- You got it.
What's your handle?
I see it here.
H-K-M...
- It's right there.
- I gotchu, my friend.
So, let me ask you a question,
you have a lot of followers
for only five posts.
Do you take down posts a lot?
- I mean, I, like, create
content for others, like,
for businesses, influencers--
- And they tag you?
- Yeah.
I don't post my own--
- Did you make,
you made this?
- No, no I didn't make it.
- Got it, got it.
- I won't lie.
- No worries, yeah don't.
Lying is bad.
I love it, brother.
Good luck.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you, Gary.
- Let's keep it goin'.
Life enhancer, it's good right?
'Preciate it Paulina.
Big shout out to the YouTube crew.
Re-stream, re-stream, re-stream.
I see everybody goin' hard on that.
Paulina Y, what's good?
Sam Ben, what's good?
Yes, that was a pitch, Sam Ben.
He completely came just for the follow
which fuck it!
I respect the hustle.
Let's keep it goin'!
Ashley, how are you?
- Hey, Gary!
- How's it goin'?
- I'm good.
How are you?
- Super well.
- Awesome, well, first and foremost,
I hope you and your family
are safe and doing well.
- We are.
Thank you, Ash.
- Awesome.
So, two questions.
First question is that,
I went to school for advertising.
I got my business degree,
and I've always loved marketing,
branding, advertising.
I moved to New York three years ago.
And, it's interesting
because I consider myself
to be really passionate
and I work really hard
and I love it!
Like, I love a company like VaynerMedia,
especially VaynerSports
because I'm a sports fanatic!
So, y'know, the two worlds colliding.
For the past three years I've had jobs,
but I've never been able to get far enough
in an interview process or really be able
to get a job or come close to a job
that I'm really passionate about.
And, I find it interesting
because I work hard
and I love it.
So, I'm just wondering
where do you think the disconnect lies
between my capabilities
and actually kinda getting
my foot in the door with it?
- You're accepting jobs.
- I'm accepting jobs.
- Okay.
- The disconnect is you've
said "yes" to people
that have offered you jobs
that weren't as ideal
as they could have been
because you didn't go hard enough
to get as many interviews
in the five to 40 places
that could be the place.
The disconnect is you've said "yes".
- Oh God, how ironic.
Okay, and so, I just...
Okay.
Yeah, I mean, mind blown.
- It is mind blowing.
It's like so fun for me.
Y'know, it's, like, there's so
many things I'm not good at.
But, like, navigating life decisions
and, like, shit like this.
There's just so much clarity for me.
Like, you're talking.
I'm listening.
I'm enjoying your vibe.
And then, it's just, y'know,
the answer is you
shouldn't have said "yes"
to the jobs you've said "yes" to,
and you should have kept going
to get interviews in the places you want.
Like, you should've spammed VaynerMedia's
thousand employees in perpetuity
until one of them got you, like, got it?
You haven't gone hard
enough in the conviction
of getting the jobs in the
places that you wanted to.
And then, what put the nail in
the coffin was you said "yes"
to the jobs that you've said "yes" to.
- Okay, well with that in mind,
I decided to go straight
to the source which is you.
And so, if you ever find the
opportunity for VaynerSports,
you let me know because sports
and marketing is my jam!
Football, my jam!
- Well, who do you like?
- I can't tell you.
You're not gonna hire me.
(laughs)
I'm a Dolphins fan!
I'm from Miami.
I'm sorry, I know.
- Do you live in Miami right now?
- I live in New York.
I'm here because of, y'know.
- Would you move to Miami
and work for the Dolphins?
- 100%.
- Why don't you send me an email right now
to gary@vaynermedia and
put in "Miami Dolphins".
I'm sure you know I'm business
partners with Steve Ross,
the owner of the Dolphins,
that I have real connections.
Or, maybe you don't know that?
- I didn't know that
'cause I would've most
definitely led with that.
But, you taught me
anyway which is awesome.
- Gary@vaynermedia, "I want
a job with the Dolphins".
Let me see what I can do.
- Gary, you're a hero.
I appreciate it.
And, I just want to say I
think it's really inspiring
that what you've done is, obviously,
you can't go to Hudson Yards.
You can't do what you do.
You can't travel,
but you're still helping
people everywhere.
And, I think it's awesome
and it inspires me.
- Thank you.
Wait 'til this next part of our chapter.
I'm gonna really help you.
Send me that email.
- Gary, you're the best.
Have a great day.
- Bye, Ash.
To answer the questions
in the comments section,
the person that's laughing
in the background is my mom
who never wants to appear
in any of my content,
but she's literally watching right there,
and she's laughing her ass off.
And it's making me laugh.
(laughs)
All right, let's keep it goin'.
- Yo, Gary!
- John, what's good?
- Hey, thanks for having me on.
Been following you for a while.
But, I'm in hospice sales, so...
If anyone doesn't know,
hospice is end of life care.
So, we go to nursing homes mainly.
They're in our main referral source.
Nursing homes have been hit
the hardest out of all of this.
Y'know, so we're not able to go in.
Our partners aren't able to go in there,
so I started a healthcare
professional group
on Facebook actually back in December
but it really took off in
March with everything going on.
So, I'm just trying to
keep everyone connected.
Helping people share their skills.
I've been doing one-on-one interviews
with different people in the care field.
Trying to provide as
much value as possible,
but I don't know how to expand on it.
- What does expand on it mean to you?
- I don't know where I want to go with it.
Like, it's doing well.
Y'know, I'm getting everyone connected,
like, last night we had
a Cinco de Mayo event.
We had new facilities
showing off their facility,
so, people can't do tours, y'know,
so they're able to show 'em off.
- You're trying to figure out
if this should be an evergreen
non-profit brand builder
or should you convert it into a business?
- Right, yeah.
And so, the people that I'm workin' with
aren't direct referral sources,
so they don't refer patients to me,
but they're good people to
have on your side, y'know,
indirect referral sources.
I like networking people together.
I've liked doing the
interviews with people.
I don't know if it's some sort of side gig
that I could put together.
- Well, let me throw something at you.
When I started making GaryVee videos
that weren't wine videos,
there was no obvious path to
what I was gonna do with it.
I just knew that building
brand and sharing my thoughts
and being a good person
would lead to opportunity.
- So, just keep going with
it and see where it ends up?
- And, it's similar to the
young lady that we just had,
y'know, it's not only going with it.
Like, doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
Like, building brand is
always the right thing.
Like, karma is the most
practical strategy in business.
Like, kindness, caring, like,
people are so confused right now
'cause there's so much political tension,
there's so much anger,
there's so much stuff going on
in our world pre-Covid that
people are super confused.
Like, the way you actually win is
by doing all the nicest
shit humanly possible.
- And that's what I'm tryin' to do, yeah.
- Like, nice guys win.
This whole, like, "nice guys
finish last" makes me laugh.
Nice guys may lose that race
that you're talking about,
the micro, but they're winning in life.
Dick faces may win that race,
but they're losing in life.
And so, doing all this stuff but also,
similar to the last call,
not saying "yes" right away
if it's not the right thing.
There's been a million opportunities
for me to monetize things
that I've said "no" to
that later I monetized and
monetized far more successfully.
So, it's not only stay the course, John,
it's when the first
opportunity comes to sell it,
to get a sponsor, to
create a referral program,
it might not be the right one
and having the strength and the foresight
and the strategy capabilities
to realize it's not the
right time to monetize
or to act on this is a huge deal.
- I appreciate that because I, actually,
I was putting out, like,
LinkedIn content too
and I started getting people
offering me different jobs.
And, I like what I'm doing now,
so I didn't wanna jump on
anything new just to jump.
Another question though,
I've been trying to put
out LinkedIn content,
hospice education videos.
- That's really cool.
- How do you do such a serious topic,
can you do that on TikTok
or anything like that?
- I don't know if TikTok,
y'know, the answer is you
can do anything on anything.
Like, hospice is, like, very heavy shit!
And so...
(chuckles)
You could, but I would
probably say that LinkedIn
and a Facebook group are
probably the smarter places
to go with that.
I think Facebook's super important.
Facebook inherently is older, y'know.
You've got a lot of 50,
60 year olds on Facebook
who are facing the extremely
sad moments of their parents
being in a place where
they're starting to get ill
or terminally ill or
things of that nature.
It's a tough subject matter to talk about.
I'm sure (laughs)
I'm sure, John, you're
like living through life
like, going to the neighborhood picnic
and it's like "Hey, I'm John."
"Hey, I'm Rick.
"What do you do?"
I'm sure you get, y'know.
I'm sure, like, people don't wanna...
The reverse for me has been
like wine and social media
and people always wanna lean in.
Just in living in real life,
you know that it's a subject matter
that's kind of tough for people.
I do think that LinkedIn
and Facebook especially,
I think is a very
powerful platform for you.
- I think Facebook's great actually
because I've been trying to get more
into the senior care groups
for the adult children.
So, even if they're not
gonna be referred to us
because we're only in
the Philadelphia area,
so if there's somewhere
that's, y'know, far away
at least I'm giving them the information
to help 'em make a decision.
- That's right, brother.
I think, keep going
and the opportunity will
absolutely show itself
and then be thoughtful
when the time is there.
And betterhalf206 is right.
Hospice is about love and caring.
It is, like, the kindest,
most noble thing.
It's just an uncomfortable subject matter
for so many people 'cause
it's, like, a death sentence
in a lot of people's minds,
but I couldn't agree
more with betterhalf206,
the humanity and just thank you
for the industry you're in, brother.
- Oh yeah, no problem.
Thank you, Gary.
- Talk to you soon.
- All right, take care.
- Take care.
Buh-bye.
Dustin.
- Yo.
- Somebody wrote that I was a goober.
I thought that would've been
a good one to flash up here.
- I wasn't sure if it was
the right time for that
while you're talking about love and care.
- Yeah, no.
Somebody razzing on me is always--
- Okay.
- There's never a wrong time
to throw up a negative comment.
- All right.
- Because I fuckin' absorb that
shit like a fuckin' monster.
- Here's another goober for you.
- God damn it!
(laughs)
All right, let's keep goin'.
ExtremeZach.
- Hows it goin'?
- Things are well, you?
- I'm doin' great.
Okay, I'll dive right into it
'cause I kinda have two
questions, if you have time?
But, so as someone who has
become a self-proclaimed expert
at right hook marketing
for my furniture store,
I'm wondering what type
of content can we make
for people that would
be more of a job content
in the context of a furniture store
that's not very design-oriented.
We're more entry level to mid-level
so people aren't necessarily so obsessed
with the furniture itself or
the real designing aspect.
- By still talking
about the utility of it.
Like, a $80 chair or $13 chair
or whatever the fuck
we're talking about here
still has information about it
that people might care about, right?
Like, I don't know, what's
the cushion feel like?
What wood's it made of?
Like, where is it made from?
For everybody who's watching
and doesn't know the
terminology we're using,
Zach's being very kind.
He's referencing to a book
that I wrote years ago called
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook",
and the concept is most
people fuck up social media,
and life for that matter,
because they just go into right hooks
which is they're trying to land the sale.
And Zach, clearly,
and this works on digital marketing,
has figured out sales content, right?
Here's a cup, $6.99.
Y'know, away we go.
And so, that's a right hook.
Going in for the sale.
I've noticed and have been
proven over the last 10 years
that people that are
best at marketing know
how to throw out value, jabs,
that also helps them close their sales.
And so, what he's asking is, y'know,
how do we find a balance
in a retail environment
where we're selling shit?
And I get where you're going, right, like,
there's obviously the
super high end things
where the designer herself or himself,
the fabric type,
I still think you talk about
utility and practicality
at that price point.
- Right, yeah, I thought about
doing things like reviewing--
- Stop right there!
Stop right there.
The whole game's breaking
because you said "I thought".
- Right, right.
- You don't need fuckin' me and "Tea",
you know where I'm going.
I fucking hate "I thought"
because every "I thought"
is a missed opportunity
from you putting out something that was.
- Absolutely, yeah.
And, okay, if you've got time here,
I've got another follow up question here.
So, I've just recently started to,
like my own advertising agency,
basically what I'm doing
for Furniture Extreme
which is the company that I work for,
to go help other furniture
stores do the same thing
with their marketing.
So, my question is, you
always talk about trying
to scale the unscalable.
We've noticed with our marketing the thing
that always indexes the best
is human interaction, right?
Then when you can put that
at scale like you talk
about all the time,
but my question is can I scale myself
for other furniture stores?
Like, would you for instance run ads
for a different wine
company, like, as Gary
as you're obviously doing that for GaryVee
or is that something that
you would kind of leave
off to the side?
Kinda torn on that, I guess.
- One more time, do you
own this furniture store?
- No, I don't own it.
I'm basically just like
a number two in command.
- You're an employee?
- I'm an employee absolutely.
- Yeah, so for me it's different
because with Wine Library
it's my family business and
with Empathy it's my business.
Y'know, I'm not an employee,
so of course I would not do
that for another wine store.
But, if I was you?
I would go start my own company.
- Right, which is what I've done here.
I mean, the interesting part is my mentor,
one of my mentors I should say,
and the owner of the business
is also a partner with me
in this because--
- Got it, so the owner of
this business and your mentor,
who you have a great relationship with,
recognize that you're
talented and instead of, like,
trying to suppress you
and not do your own thing,
came in and is a partner in this business?
- He would never suppress me.
- That's awesome.
- Tim's watchin' right now and Tim--
- Tim, I have so much respect for you.
Tim is doing something that I
have the most admiration for,
which is super hard.
Sometimes they catch
a young talent by the,
tiger by the tail,
they know they've got something good.
It's helping their business.
That person doesn't own the business.
Sure, they can pay them more,
but a lot of time when that kid realizes,
"Wait a minute, I want to
do something for myself."
And they go, that owner resents
it or tries to suppress it
or tries to not make it
happen instead of leaning in.
The biggest thing I've learned
in my life is you can't stop winners.
- Right.
- That's a great job by Tim.
Big shout out to Tim on that.
What's the question on that?
- My question is, again, like,
can I or should I,
I know I sort of can,
but I can scale myself
within Furniture Extreme
and me, like, sitting on the couch
and stuff like that works really well.
Me talking about this "come on in",
all that sort of stuff.
But if I'm running ads for another store--
- I see.
No, I think you need to build them up.
- Okay.
For instance, like,
there's a different store
in Edmonton for instance.
Like, could I kind of almost,
like, white label myself
and be like "I'm Zach, not ExtremeZach"
but I'm Zach here with this store?
- Yes, yes, as long as Tim's cool with it.
- Right, yeah that's true.
I would never do it if he wasn't, so--
- I believe that I can tell.
The answer's "yes" when
and if you guys have that conversation.
- Right, okay.
- And if you get good at
building up other people,
notice what I do with my content.
I made Chris Mott and Eric
Kastner stars on Wine Library TV.
I made India and Stunman, right?
Look what's goin' on with Dustin!
Look at this face.
Dustin show 'em your fuckin' face.
Look!
Dustin's never been so
popular in his fuckin' life.
He doesn't know what to
do with his newfound fame!
Dustin, you're totally confused, right?
Tell everybody, you're fuckin' confused.
- Very confused.
- Yeah, get outta here!
So, Zach, what I do is I use my platform
and I cosign people and what's happening?
Dustin's getting bombarded
with fuckin' 400 people, like
"Be my podcast guy."
You don't think D Rock and Dustin have,
like D Rock has unlimited options.
D Rock could make 10 times
more money by leaving me
but he realizes for himself
that a) he likes me, I assume,
D Rock I love you
and b) he can go on and win with me longer
'cause he feels that's the way.
What you can do is you can
go into those other stores
and sit on the couch with
the owner of that store
and create that cosign.
- So, I guess my question is,
so I can do that but the
problem I'm running into is
that, like, for instance
even in the other store
that's only like a
three hour drive for me,
it's, like, I'm so busy
at Furniture Extreme,
like working on that.
To even drive the three hours,
I can do that a couple times
a month that sorta thing,
but I can't scale that
if I was to get a client
in my hometown in California
for instance, so is that,
I don't wanna lean into
something that I can't scale,
I guess, but I'm always
trying to scale the things
that are un-scalable,
like you talk about the--
- Both.
Both!
I scale un-scalable things,
and I built a thousand
person infrastructure.
And by the way,
that thousand person infrastructure
started with one person.
- Right, so basically, do
what you can with that side,
and then--
- And, don't just be niche to furniture.
- Right.
Well how do you mean, I guess?
Elaborate on that?
- Storytelling for, if you're an agency,
you know the tactics.
You may not be the expert
for the subject matter,
but you'd surely know how to,
based on running ads and creating content,
you know what's working
on social networks,
so you can deploy that
without being the face
of the flower shop or the baker
or the fuckin' real estate agent.
- Yeah, exactly.
That's what I was kinda
thinking originally
with doing it but then I was, like,
y'know some of the things
that work the best is,
literally, like, a selfie
video where I'm just sitting
on the couch and I'm talkin',
and I'm like this is the
best ad we've ever run
or one of them, and I'm like--
- Then you can direct
somebody else to do it.
- Right, kinda give them the instructions.
- You don't need to be the face.
Listen, Zach, I know you
got a great fuckin' face
but you don't need to be in
every fuckin' piece of content.
You can tell Karen to be in her content.
And Karen may suck as
the flower shop person,
and then you have to go another route
or Karen might be more
charismatic and it will work.
Like that Russian sofiero lady yesterday.
Y'know she's gonna win.
- I guess I have a hard
time sometimes just,
like you're saying.
Certain people are better on camera,
certain people aren't,
and it just seems like
in the furniture industry
that's kinda been a hard
thing to find other people
who are sorta like that.
- I promise you, Zach, you're
not the only talented person
in the furniture industry.
And I'm sure your first video sucked.
But, so that's what I mean,
like, I get it theoretically,
but you've gotta deal in reality.
Like, I get it.
- Right.
No, that makes sense, man.
I'm comin' to see you in Edmonton.
Pre-Covid we were supposed to--
- I know.
And I know it's been re-booked
and I hope it sticks.
But, I will get my ass to Edmonton.
I'm fuckin' obsessed with it.
- I'm bringing my GaryVee sneakers.
My boss has four pairs.
He knows they're gonna be
worth some day a whole bunch
when you buy the Jets.
If you're watchin' this,
buy those shoes 'cause if you buy the Jets
those are gonna be worth millions.
- Thank you, brother.
Talk to you seen.
- Yeah, see you, Gary.
- Take care, Zach.
I don't know about millions,
but I definitely expect
GaryVees to be flipping
in 25 years for at least a thousand.
And I think they're about a
hundred on Ebay now, so...
Free money!
If you're willing to wait 25 years.
All right, let's keep goin'.
James, what's good?
- Hey, I'm good.
How are you?
- I'm good.
It's really good to see you, bro.
- It's good to see you.
First, I wanna thank you for
this opportunity, y'know.
Shit is priceless, and those
sneakers is gonna be priceless.
(laughs)
- I appreciate it.
- I've been watchin'
your videos for a minute
and today I'm lookin' for tactics, y'know.
There is a lot of shit I wanna do, y'know.
I know what I wanna do!
I saw an old "DailyVee"
where this lady asked
how she could manage multiple projects.
And you know she wasn't worried
about spreading too thin.
It was confusion for her.
For me, it's dividing my time, y'know.
I'm not splittin' my focus.
Putting my all in to each project.
- Okay?
- So, I was just wonderin'
how could I divide my time?
- By dividing it.
- Okay.
Fair enough, very fair.
- But, play with me here.
- Okay.
- Like,
what's the struggle?
- The struggle is, like, I
just got too much shit going on
and, like, I just can't, like,
focus on one thing at a time
and then move to the next thing.
Y'know what I mean?
Like, they're very different.
- What are they?
- One thing is creative
and then one thing's,
like, more finance, y'know?
- Okay.
I think you can switch to them.
I just think that you might
just be beating yourself up
and have decided that
because you have two things
that you're not accomplishing either
because you're stretched too thin.
Like, what's making you
think you can't balance it?
- Probably myself, y'know.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
If you told me, like, they
all failed that's the results.
But, I think a lot of people
just create an ideology
or, like, one person they respect or like
or they think is successful
tells them that they need
to focus on one thing and
then just believe them.
Like, why can't you balance
the creative thing you're doing
and the finance thing you're doing?
I would argue you are balancing them.
As long as one of them
doesn't go out of business
or as long as one doesn't
bring you deep unhappiness,
you actually are balancing them.
I think people just get
into philosophy for no fuckin' reason.
- Nah, for real.
I appreciate that.
And yeah, just one more question.
- Please.
- When I don't have an audience to ask
how do I figure out the
best way to provide value
and engage them, y'know?
Like, I don't give a fuck
about the followers to likes,
like I want 17 real followers
that comment on every post.
- By making.
By making.
- Making?
- By making because you're
gonna have one piece of content.
Have you started TikTok?
- Nah (laughs)
- James, listen to me,
TikTok is free audience.
For everybody who's listening,
and by the way I see you Twitch.
You're almost at 10,000 people.
I fuck with you guys on Twitch!
You guys are really going at it hard.
TikTok is free audience, bro.
You know that I was gonna
ask you that question.
How the fuck did you
come on here this morning
and not set up a TikTok
account before we got on here?
It's free audience!
- You're right.
- I know I'm right.
It's free fuckin' audience!
You want 17 real fans?
Make one TikTok when we hang up right now
and you got it.
Your big fuckin' dream of 17, James?
I just fuckin' gave it to you.
Hang the fuck up.
Make a TikTok of you
brushing your fuckiing teeth!
And you've got 17 free fans.
- All right.
- All right, bet.
- I'll see you, Gary.
Hey, one last request!
You know when you're in Edmonton,
can I link you up?
Is that cool?
- 100%.
100% let's go.
Damn, everyone's from fucking Edmonton.
- Nah, I'm down south.
Peace!
- Peace.
All right, let's keep it goin'.
Enough, like, hey hi.
- Hi, Gary, how's it goin'?
- Good.
What's your name?
- My name is Tori.
- Tori, it's so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
So, I'm a photographer and videographer.
I'm based in central Florida.
I focus mainly on weddings and portraits,
things like that.
I studied art and photography
all through college,
and I worked really hard
to keep myself out of debt.
I worked, like, multiple jobs.
I've done everything I can to, y'know,
I went to college knowing I
wanted to own my own business.
I didn't, y'know, do it
because anyone told me to.
I viewed it as my business investment.
- And, so I've carried that
mentality of, like, being
financially safe with my
money, like, into my business.
And I feel like it might
be holding me back?
- You're not investing enough.
- What's that?
- You're not investing enough
'cause you're very
conservative with the dollars.
- Right, so things like
WeddingWire, The Knot,
going to wedding expos, things like that--
- Try it!
Let me give you an example.
I ran for Wine Text.
Ooh good segway, get in here, Dustin.
For Wine Text, right?
I ran an ad in a 300,000
person email newsletter
from one of the biggest wine,
kind of, companies this week,
two days ago, right?
I couldn't wait, like,
it was like Christmas.
I couldn't wait to, y'know,
see how it was gonna do.
But, I also knew and I even
told my fam, I was like...
I even told a story about one
of my worst advertising moments
when I bought a huge ad
on luxury.com in 1997
for Wine Library,
and I thought it was
gonna change our company.
We got like two orders
and I spent like $10,000
which was like a billion dollars
for that small business at the time.
And, punchline is on
Monday it didn't do well.
Like, it just didn't do well.
And, I was thrilled
because I got the learning,
and I could afford it.
It was a lot of money,
but I could afford it.
My dad's company could afford it.
That was why the decision was made.
You have to not fear being wrong,
and you have to not value the cash.
Cash is king, but when it holds you back.
I think you're being very self aware.
I think you can feel it.
So, what I would say is this,
everything you just brought up,
The Knot, expos, things of that nature,
you have to do them
when you can afford it to go to zero.
Like, Tori, you know
how you paid for school
and fuckin' worked your fuckin' face off?
You need to realize the education
of doing an expo, the
education of doing The Knot,
the execution of doing the Wire,
the execution of paying a
wedding influencer a fortune,
right?
You need to realize that you doing that
is you paying for an education.
But better than fucking college,
you might actually be right half the time
and it pays it back immediately.
You need to convert it not into
"I made a bad business
decision and I lost the money."
You need to convert it into
"I'm gonna learn from this
and if it goes to zero
"it's just gonna be a funny
fuckin' story I tell one day
"just like Gary did about luxury.com."
- Right.
- If I ever find you
fuckin' luxury.com fuckers
that ripped me off I'm
gonna punch you in the neck.
Anyway, Tori, that's the game.
- Right.
- If you can go to zero,
every decision has to be
"I'm gonna spend 8,000 on this
"and if it goes to zero I won't die."
- Right (chuckles)
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- Is that how you think about it?
- Yeah because right
now I'm only three years
in to really trying to
get my business started up
and I'm working a part-time job still.
I work at a photography museum and it's...
It takes up a lot of my time,
so being able to work from
home has kind of, like,
been a nice taste of
what I'm hoping to get to
where I can work my business full-time.
So, that's where I'm at.
I'm still not financially able
to do my photography full-time
I have to--
- I have great news.
- Yes?
- You're super young.
- I mean, I know, but (laughs)
- No, no, no, see, the funniest part of
that sentence is you can't
put the "but" in there.
Take the "but" out and go
back to the part of "I know".
- Right.
- How old are you?
- I'll be 30 in January.
- I worked in a liquor
store when I was 30.
- Yeah.
I know, I'm impatient, I know that--
- Tori!
At 30 I worked in a liquor store
and when it was the holidays
I would literally ring up
people, I was a cashier.
I would literally stock shelves.
I would literally pack boxes
and have them ship out.
That's what I was doing.
- Yeah, and I'm not
afraid of the hard work.
- Clearly!
Clearly!
You're impatient for the thing you love.
- Yeah.
- Your day job is,
are you maximizing dollars there?
Are you learning something there?
Like, is it just a job?
- Right now, it's been great
because it is within my field of interest.
It's at a museum, photography,
but it's a desk job.
And it's not my passion,
and it's a paycheck.
- I think for a lot of people like you
you need to get more
strategic about the paycheck.
Like, what I would be doing probably
at all times is applying for other jobs
that either give me more dollars
so I can invest so I can leave.
Or something that may
lead to more opportunities
or I enjoy even more.
Being the right hand of somebody
who I admire 10 times over as
a much better photographer.
I think where you're miss playing it,
and I see a lot of people
commenting about this,
so it's resonating, is the strategy
of "just a paycheck" needs to be smarter.
And, for a lot of people here,
they need to work at 7-Eleven,
so they can be on their
phone the whole time building
up their personal brand
and make less money than they are at a job
that pays them two times more
but they have no time
during the eight hour day
because they actually
have to do their job.
So, they have to take even a shittier job.
But, that's a strategy!
You might need to take a
job that pays you even more
that you might even like less
because like you said
it's a desk job anyway.
So yeah, the facade is it's in your field
but it's not in your fuckin' field.
So why not make 8,000 more a
year by taking some other job
'cause that strategy gives
you that 8,000, 6,000 post tax
to put into The Knot or do the thing
that could change your game.
Or take less than the desk job
but then become the apprentice
or right hand or gopher
of the greatest photographer
that you've ever witnessed.
You have to get much more
strategic about your day job.
- Right.
Okay.
I guess that's kind of where I'm at too.
I've been in Daytona and it's
about an hour out from Orlando
which is where most of my clients
for my photography come from.
And I've been meaning
to get back to Orlando
'cause that's where I'm originally from,
but my job is keeping me in Daytona.
- I wanna punch your
job in the fuckin' face!
(laughs)
I'm gonna fuckin' go down to Daytona,
during spring break of course,
and then quickly go over and
punch your job in its face.
Your fuckin' job is pissing me off, Tor.
- Me too, sometimes.
- You need to apply to 800 fuckin',
I don't give a,
get in a fuckin' Pluto costume
and work in fuckin' Disney.
I don't give a fuck!
Get the fuck to Orlando!
- Okay (laughs)
- I'm being serious.
Get your ass to fuckin' Orlando!
- Okay.
- What're we doing here?
The job has no fucking value.
You're just in a fuckin' hamster wheel.
- Right.
- Get the fuck out of that job!
Now, of course this happens
when 50 million fuckin'
people lose their jobs,
so it's not, like, y'know,
the timing is fucking whack!
However, that doesn't stop
you applying to 800 jobs!
Like, the fuck are we doing here?
- I think I'm scared to...
Because I'm always so,
like, "what's the next goal?
"What's the next goal?"
I'm scared to take the step
backwards to take a job that--
- The fuck we been doin'
here for fuckin' a month
on "Tea With GaryVee",
humility is the fuckin' super power.
Humility is the unlock.
You need to be humble.
- Right.
- Tori, you need to be humble.
Like, I need to go to a Knicks Magic game
when they get back to playing,
go to the stadium, sit there,
and see you serving some fuckin' popcorn.
And then I'm gonna say "That
fuckin' girl's on her way!"
- Right.
- Humility, get your
fuckin' ass to Orlando!
People are goin' crazy about your photos.
Let's put up your Instagram again.
- Thanks.
- People are goin' nuts!
- Anyone in Florida
getting married, hire me!
(laughs)
- Listen to me,
get to fuckin' Orlando.
And that means applying
to 500 jobs this week,
and that's what you do
for three hours at night.
For real!
And by the way, there
are a lot of businesses
that are exploding during this time.
There's a lot that are struggling,
going out of business.
On the flip side, there's
a lot that are growing.
- Yeah, I've been getting
lots of inquiries lately,
so I've not been feeling
any sort of, y'know,
heat from this.
It's actually been kind of nice to--
- Tori, is there anything
keeping you in Daytona
that I don't know about?
- Just the job.
Just the constant paycheck.
The security of that.
- It blows my face off that people
in this generation don't
use the internet at night
to get them out of their fuckin' jail.
You need to be fuckin'
applying for jobs 24-7,
two hours a fuckin' night.
In fucking Orlando.
- Right.
Okay.
- Two hours a night, Tor.
- Two hours, yep.
- Two hours.
Awesome.
- I can do that.
Thanks so much!
- You're welcome, take care.
All right, good show today.
I really appreciate
everybody being on today.
What a great day.
What did we get to on Twitch?
Did we break that 10,000 barrier?
I know we were...
- We did.
- Unbelievable.
- Maybe like 10,000 and point seven,
something like that.
- I mean, like, they went ham!
- Yeah, I couldn't keep
up with the comments.
It's going too crazy.
- No, it's really really good.
I'm really really grateful to Twitch.
I saw something like
number 28 on the rankings.
We have to get the team together
and really go get serious about Twitch.
We need some emojis of my face.
There's a ton of cultural
things we need to do in there.
Tyler's gonna finally shine.
He's obsessed, so...
And then, I'm gonna get
Bugga to fuckin' re-stream me
and then we'll really get
into the fuckin' game.
- That'd be sick.
- So, really appreciate it.
Thank you so much for
everybody who joined in.
For a lot of the new,
how many people are in
here for the first time?
Comments, if this is
your first time watching
just put in "first"
just curious about that.
And also, when we end up here...
Nice, a lot of "first"s, let's go.
Twitch coming in hard!
I love it.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you so much.
I'm just very humbled.
I will see you tomorrow.
And most of all, I know a
ton of you have not signed up
for the podcast.
Been looking at some data.
So, if you want to hear more
positivity consistently,
especially 'cause I'm
worried that post-Covid
there will be no "Tea With GaryVee",
it is time for you to
subscribe to the podcast
which is absolutely the
morning alternative.
Here it is.
I realize a lot of you that
watch "Tea With GaryVee"
aren't singed up for my podcast.
That makes me sad.
Here's what you're missing out on.
If you do not follow the
podcast you're missing out.
Listening to podcasts
is as efficient as fuck
when you're traveling,
when you're commuting to work,
when you're on the fucking treadmill.
Listen, I get Drizzy's
dropping great albums.
I understand but get your
fucking knowledge up.
Win for you, don't consume
somebody else's music.
Consume some shit that will get you yours!
Link up, sign up, right
now to the fucking podcast.
If you're not listening,
you're fucking up.
Get your summer right.
Get on the podcast.
Link in the profile.
Get on it.
Subscribe.
Leave a comment if you just did.
Leave a comment if you've been on.
I love you.